constate que les demandes enfin que les
porteurs de projet et donc les
demandeurs d'emploi ont souvent des
difficultés à à comprendre comment
fonctionne enfin les différentes étapes
à en quoi consistent les différentes
étapes de la création d'entreprise au
sein de Pôle Emploi donc on propose à
nos créateurs ENF à nos porteurs de
projet différents ateliers qui leur
permet justement de d'avoir une vision
un petit peu plus générale un peu plus
globale sur la création d'entreprise une
des difficultés donc c'est c'est de
vraiment d'identifier les différentes
étapes de la création d'entreprise
l'autre difficulté si je peux le dire
également c'est au niveau du financement
c'est vrai que pour créer une entreprise
il faut également du financement il faut
qu'il réfléchisse il faut qu'il qu'il
pèse bien on va dire le pour et le
contre avant toute création d'entreprise
parce que c'est c'est quand même un
véritable challenge un challenge donc il
est important quand même de de de se
faire bien enfin d'être bien informé
d'être bien accompagné également que ce
soit par nous ou par d'autres structures
qui uvrent dans le dans le cadre de la
création d'entreprise la création
d'entreprise on va dire est peut être
pour tout public mais il faut quand même
prendre le temps euh d'étudier son
projet de se faire aider de prendre
suffisamment de recul euh c'est
peut-être ce qui manque aussi de temps
en temps à nos porteurs de projets de
prendre suffisamment de recul
d'anticiper et surtout de se faire
accompagner et informer comme il se
doit